so
matt gates
[Music]
sponsored by ting mobile lightly giggles
it's time to think like a very busy
criminal defense lawyer because
what is going on with the matt gates
scandal and i'm afraid we're gonna have
to be more specific than that
because it appears that there is a
scandal inside of a scandal inside of a
scandal it's like one of those
russian nesting dolls but it's all
florida men
all the way down but the question is did
any of matt gates's alleged
relationships break the law
are the wild stories about matt gates
and his father just a pack of lies
dreamed up by two men who were trying to
blackmail the gates family
or does it hold some truth so let's go
through the timeline of allegations
against congressman gates and see if any
of these allegations might give rise to
illegal conduct and
let me stress that at this point these
allegations are all unproven he denies
everything and there are conflicting
accounts
but one thing is certain that if you
thought that weird political scandals
were going to end with the trump
administration
you haven't been paying attention to
florida man so let's start at the
beginning in late march political news
sites reported that gates was thinking
about not running for re-election
and becoming a talking head on the news
organization newsmax
some reported that he was even thinking
about ending his term early so that he
could
join the private sector but this left a
lot of people scratching their heads
about why a young congressman would
consider newsmax a promotion
well as we would soon learn the
department of justice was apparently
investigating gates for federal crimes
and here's some free hashtag not legal
advice working for cable tv
does not give you any immunity from
prosecution but not long after the new
york times reported that the doj was
investigating gage for possibly having
had a sexual relationship with a 17 year
old and paying her to travel with him
not surprisingly several federal
statutes make it illegal to induce
someone under the age of 18 to travel
over state lines to engage in sex in
exchange for money or something of value
the main federal law is 8 usc 1591 which
prohibits sex trafficking of children by
force fraud or coercion
and for purposes of this law a minor is
someone under the age of 18 years old
this statute also makes it a federal
offense to knowingly recruit entice
harbor transport provide obtain
or maintain a minor knowing or in
reckless disregard of the fact that the
victim is a minor
and would be caused to engage in a
commercial sex act and that is defined
exactly the way you would think it was
now section 1591 does not require proof
that either the defendant or victim
crossed
state lines or international lines the
prosecution also doesn't need to prove
that defendant used forced threats of
force fraud or coercion
but if the victim was between 14 and 17
years old the penalty is a minimum
sentence of
10 years in prison up to life now gates
has denied the charges and told the new
york times quote
i have a suspicion that someone is
trying to recategorize my generosity to
ex-girlfriends as something more
untoward which sort of raises the
question
how do you mischaracterize generosity
toward someone who is not
a minor in this context but that is a
question for
another time and here there are reports
that the alleged 17 year old victim was
also involved in a felony sex
trafficking count against joel greenberg
greenberg is a former seminole county
florida tax collector who's been charged
with 33 counts from
four indictments including sex
trafficking with a minor whom gates was
allegedly involved with now greenberg is
also one of gates's florida pals here
they are goofing around with
known upstanding citizen roger stone and
here they are
at the white house now greenberg became
the youngest tax collector in the
county's history and allegedly has spent
over one million dollars on guns body
armor and his own cryptocurrency scheme
and drone while in office and in 2017
greenberg pulled over a woman he thought
was speeding to scold her
while he wore his tax collector's badge
that resembled a
sheriff's badge and for some reason he
even had flashing police lights on the
top of his suv
now amazingly the florida state attorney
wrote in a letter that greenberg was
quote
being given the benefit of the doubt
that his intentions were pure
therefore he did not commit the crime of
impersonating a police officer
and look i've been to florida so that
does seem to check out but that probably
wouldn't fly in any other context in any
other state
but in 2018 gates publicly endorsed
greenberg's bid for re-election
saying that one day greenberg would make
a fine member of congress
i'll pause to let that one sink in but
greenberg was then charged with stalking
and harassing a teacher
who was running against him in the
republican primary greenberg had
apparently set up fake online profiles
to defame the teacher and sent several
letters to the school where he worked
saying that the man engaged in
inappropriate conduct with his students
in july of 2019
gates and greenberg left obnoxious
voicemails on the cell phone of florida
state representative anna esquimani
a democrat saying this is your favorite
tax collector i'm up in the panhandle
with your favorite us congressman
mr gates hi anna then in august of 2020
greenberg was indicted on 14 more counts
including sex trafficking charges
related to a minor between the ages of
14 and 17. now unfortunately the details
of greenberg's alleged trafficking
scheme are also essential to
understanding why gates is in hot water
first
federal prosecutors allege that
greenberg used his position as
tax collector to access the florida
driver and vehicle information database
where he would research women and girls
some of the individuals greenberg
researched were involved in
sugar daddy relationships with greenberg
and greenberg allegedly abused his
position and took surrender driver's
licenses before they were shredded by
his office staff
and created new ideas with his
photograph but with the personal
information of his residents
and not surprisingly during a search
police found fake ids in greenberg's
office and materials used to create
those ids as well
greenberg of course denies all of these
allegations which takes us back to
congressman gates
gates allegedly visited the seminole
county tax collector's office at least
twice after hours according to text
messages reviewed by the orlando
sentinel and the daily beast
and on april 16 2018 greenberg visited
the lake mary florida branch of his tax
collection agency
surveillance footage captured greenberg
standing near a desk with another man
but greenberg forgot to set the alarm on
the way out which concerned the
assistant branch manager when she went
to work on monday morning
that employee found driver's licenses
scattered all over the desk instead of
in the appropriate disposal basket
she reviewed the camera footage and
alerted her boss who sent greenberg a
text message saying
quote did you happen to visit the lake
mary office on the weekend
the daily beast reports that greenberg
responded yes i was showing congressman
gates
what our operation looked like did i
leave something on and according to the
daily beast text messages show that
greenberg was helping gates get some
duplicate ids they report that
on september 2nd 2018 greenberg directly
asked an employee to quickly create a
new card that complies with the
heightened security standards of real id
a process that would
normally require providing additional
documentation according to the images
the daily beast goes on to report that
greenberg texted one of his employees
quote
amy is there any way to assist one of
our congressmen in getting an emergency
replacement id or dl by tuesday 2 pm
he was lost yesterday and he's got a
flight tuesday doesn't have any other
form of id currently on him sorry to
bother you on a sunday
greenberg then confirmed that the favor
was for quote matthew lewis gates jr
born may 7 1982. if you didn't know
gates represents northwest florida while
greenberg was tax collector in seminole
county which is 472 miles away
from gates district so why did gates
need the tax collector from outside his
district to create ids for him
these are of course red flags so when
the secret service was apparently
investigating greenberg for identity
theft
they discovered the link to gates and
shortly before the story about gates
broke
greenberg was indicted yet again this
time for allegedly submitting false
claims to receive pandemic relief aid
from the government
and trying to bribe a government
official yes greenberg allegedly did all
of this
after his other legal troubles and
reports say that the independent gates
investigation was launched
under the trump administration and that
attorney general bill barr was briefed
on the matter and actively tried to
avoid
meeting gates in person because of
potential improprieties
given the ongoing investigation and
there is yet more evidence that the
gates greenberg investigation involves
other florida
officials a woman told investigators
that she had had sex with greenberg
gates and another guy involved in
florida gop politics
several sources told reporters from
floridapolitics.com that the third man
is former florida department of business
and professional regulations secretary
hazley beshears who resigned in january
the woman allegedly was a minor at the
time of the sexual encounter and several
reporters say that she had already
testified in front of a grand jury
about having had sex with matt gates and
according to another unnamed florida
republican who claims to be influential
in state politics
greenberg texted him on august 14th and
started fuming about the investigation
the source claims that greenberg was
paying the legal fees for the woman who
allegedly slept with gates and greenberg
quote greenberg initially referred to
the young woman as vintage 99 referring
to the year she was born 1999.
pro tip putting inculpatory evidence in
digital form
especially when you're talking about the
birth date of a minor
really not the best way to conduct
criminal activity according to reports
greenberg wrote
i'm having to pay for vintage 99 to
retain a lawyer
they the federal agents contacted her
and are wanting to her to talk
she doesn't want to talk to them now
paying for someone's legal fees is not
necessarily illegal but it does raise a
whole host of questions
uh the woman in question is now
allegedly 20 but was
allegedly 17 at the time of the
encounter and the friend said that
greenberg and gates
shared girlfriends and paid their bills
and after the investigation started
greenberg apparently reached out to his
friends stating
i'm trying to let everyone know who came
into contact with any of these girls the
feds are going through my venmo history
and don't want anyone to be caught off
guard to which one of greenberg's
friends responded promptly by saying
that he wasn't on venmo and had no such
history with any of these women
and quote absolutely positively leave my
name
out of any of this i'm serious about
this joel and meanwhile the third man in
the white house photo op with greenberg
and gates
has been identified his name is chris
dorworth a former member of the florida
legislature who was close with gates
dorworth quit his job with a lobbying
firm late last week
and his presence has now been scrubbed
from the firm's website doorworth and
gates allegedly plotted to run a sham
party candidate during a state senate
race to help out jason brodeur
another friend of gates the two men said
they probably didn't discuss running a
sham candidate and dorworth added
there would be nothing illegal about it
if we had greenberg may also have some
dirt on other florida politicians as
well
he allegedly used taxpayer money to pay
for other florida politicians and wwe
wrestler matt morgan
known as blueprint for quote consulting
services
auditors have yet to find the
documentation for what these payments
were actually for
morgan happened to owe about forty
thousand dollars in federal taxes and
the consulting payments happened to be
for about forty thousand dollars
florida voters later elected blueprint
to the longwood city commission
because of course they did this is
florida after all
and back to greenberg sources told the
new york times that greenberg would find
women on
sugar daddy websites forums that would
connect people who would go on dates in
exchange for gifts fine dining travel
and allowances
and presumably have sex with them he
would then allegedly introduce these
women
to gates who would also have sex with
him
and the report said that the men would
meet women to form mutually beneficial
relationships
between the two parties but this
probably goes without saying
but in america you cannot pay for sex
without breaking the law so let's talk
about the crime of solicitation
the new york times originally reported
that greenberg and gates had paid women
for sex using cash app and apple pay
stating quote the times has reviewed
receipts from cash app a mobile payments
app and apple pay that show payments
from mr gates and mr greenberg
to one of the women and a payment from
mr greenberg to a second woman the woman
told their friends the payments were for
sex with the two men according to two
people familiar with the conversations
in encounters during 2019 and 2020 mr
gates and mr greenberg instructed the
women to meet at certain times and
places
often at hotels around florida and would
tell them the amount of money they were
willing to pay according to the messages
and interviews
and additionally the daily beast reports
that they obtained records the two men
also used venmo
to pay the women for sex again allegedly
two of the transactions are from may of
2018 when gates sent greenberg 900
the first transaction from gates says
test the second paid greenberg 900
with a memo reading hit up blank using a
nickname for one of the girls
six hours later greenberg paid three
young women nine hundred dollars
in the memo line for the payments
greenberg wrote tuition school
and school one of the girls had just
turned 18 about six months before the
transaction so the report does not name
her
and according to the daily beast gates's
venmo transactions were once public but
they disappeared this week as the
investigation moves forward
just a reminder you may want to set all
of your venmo transactions to private
whether you're doing something illegal
or not not legal advice the daily beast
was also able to confirm that the
circles of contact between gates and
greenberg overlap using venmo records
instagram and campaign finance records
quote gates and greenberg share two
direct venmo connections with women who
receive payments from greenberg
greenberg is also accused of misusing
taxpayer funds with at least three
hundred thousand dollars allegedly being
used for hotels travel
meals consulting and even cash advances
on a county credit card which takes us
to the possible crime of enticement of a
minor
if greenberg and gates had contact with
minors using technology
like these sugar daddy websites or text
messages or payment apps
if that's true they could be charged
with violating 18 usc 2422
which makes it a crime to use the us
mail or certain technologies such as the
internet
telephone to persuade induce entice or
coerce a minor to engage in prostitution
or any other illegal sexual activity it
is possible that these alleged acts
might give rise to a violation of the
man
act as well but there's also the
international travel aspect of this
federal investigators are also looking
into a bahamas trip that gates allegedly
took in late 2018 or early 2019 with a
marijuana entrepreneur the marijuana guy
allegedly paid for the travel
accommodations
and female escorts but even if the other
guy was responsible that wouldn't
necessarily get gates off the hook
because 18 usc 2423 makes it a felony to
quote knowingly transport an individual
who has not attained the age of 18 years
in interstate or foreign commerce
with the intent that the individual
engage in prostitution or any sexual
activity
for which a person can be charged with a
criminal offense
this law targets human trafficking of
underage people
the minimum penalty for this offense is
10 years and the maximum is life
and additionally the new york times
reports that gates was allegedly using
drugs quote some of the men and women
took ecstasy in a legal mood altering
drug
before having sex including mr gates two
people familiar with the encounters said
now of course there are the
drug violations themselves but if this
is true gates has legal exposure under
the trafficking person's protection act
of 2000
which makes it illegal to coerce any
person adult or child into sex acts
and in the past federal prosecutors have
filed trafficking charges against people
suspected of providing drugs in exchange
for sex
because facilitating another person's
drug habit can be a form of coercion
and then there's the issue of paying for
hotel stays and meals in exchange for
some sort of relationship
the times reported that gates had a
cover story for anyone asking about his
relationships
quote in some cases mr gates asks women
to help find others who
might be interested in having sex with
him and his friends according to two
people familiar with those conversations
should anyone acquire about their
relationships one person said mr gates
told the women to say that he had paid
for hotel rooms and dinners as part of
their dates
and cnn spoke to two women who claim to
have attended several parties with
greenberg and gates
some of the parties took place after gop
political events
they say that they shared drugs like
cocaine and ecstasy at the parties and
witnessed matt gates taking pills she
said that he behaved like a quote frat
type of party boy
it probably goes without saying but if
gates did in fact use campaign
funds for illegal activities or even
non-campaign activities that could
certainly give rise to a campaign
finance violation
cnn has reviewed receipts indicating
that greenberg and gates use digital
payment apps to send hundreds of dollars
to at least one woman at these parties
one receipt had a label indicating the
payment was for travel and one of the
women told cnn that greenberg sent her
money after some of these parties
she confirmed that some of the money was
payment for sex but she did not disclose
who she slept with
the woman said that she did not receive
money directly from gates and greenberg
allegedly bragged about partying with
gates
a source close to greenberg alleges that
he often quote sent identically worded
messages
to multiple women inviting them to
parties through these so-called sugar
daddy dating websites
if this is true prosecutors would need
evidence proving that there was some
coercion because
generally speaking it's not illegal to
pay for hotels and dinner or give gifts
as long as the people are actually both
adults and along these lines gates has
defended his actions saying quote
i definitely in my single days provided
for women i've dated
you know i've paid for flights for hotel
rooms i've been you know generous as a
partner
i think someone is trying to make that
look criminal when it's not and then
there is the issue
of the potential nude photos on his
phone
gates allegedly showed other lawmakers
photos and videos of nude women he had
said he had slept with even showing
pictures
on the house floor now is talking about
sexual relationships a crime
no not necessarily but given the context
it is possible there was some illegality
first of all if
the photos or videos are of a minor girl
you can understand exactly why that
would be illegal and additionally if the
photos or videos were taken without
consent
that could also be a crime washington dc
is one of the few jurisdictions with a
so-called revenge porn law
this revenge porn law criminalizes the
dissemination of sexually explicit
photographs
of anyone without his or her consent but
these revenge porn laws are not without
controversy because they criminalize
some form of
sexting and are not necessarily
pornographic and then there are also the
first amendment implications former
democratic representative katie hill
resigned after her ex-husband shared
nude photos of her and a conservative
website and british tabloid published
those pictures
he'll quit and filed a lawsuit against
the tabloid for violating california's
revenge porn law
but just this week a california court
ruled that the publication was protected
by the first amendment
and ironically hill and gates formed an
unlikely friendship when she was in
congress
now grand jury proceedings are supposed
to remain secret and we don't know for
sure if one is actually looking at matt
gates however things are certainly
looking grim for the congressman on that
front
on april 8 greenberg's lawyer told the
media that his client was negotiating a
plea deal with prosecutors i'm sure matt
gates is not feeling very comfortable
today
that's certainly a warning shot and if
you're matt gates's attorney that's not
something you want to hear from
other defendants and then in perhaps the
weirdest twist of all on the same day
that the allegations against gates
became public
he appeared on fox news with tucker
carlson gates denied the allegations
and then things got super weird when he
said that he was the victim of an
extortion plot what is happening is an
extortion of me and my family
involving a former department of justice
official gates also used it as an
opportunity to remind tucker carlson of
that time that he had dinner with gates
and one of his girlfriends
you and i went to dinner about two years
ago your wife was there and
i brought a friend of mine you'll
remember her i i don't remember the
woman you're speaking of or the context
at all honestly and then he pointed out
that carlson knows what it's like to be
falsely accused of
sex crimes i'm not the only person on
screen right now who's been falsely
accused
of a terrible sex act you were accused
of something that you did not do and so
you know what this feels like
which is not a great way to ensure that
you get a friendly interview
in the future but you should know that
even if these extortion
allegations are true it's entirely
possible for gates to be a victim of
extortion
while also being investigated for
illegal things that they actually have
done
often the only way to extort someone is
that they
engaged in some sort of illegal conduct
but at this point
we don't know where the fabrications
start and end
and specifically gates says the two
former government officials found out
about the investigation and tried to
shake down the gates family gates said
that his father had actually been
wearing a wire in order to help the fbi
catch the alleged extorters don gates is
a former florida senate president who
was the wealthiest member of the florida
legislature the case family actually
became extremely wealthy through the
hospice care industry
and the senior gates has backed his
son's claim
of course the two individuals accused of
blackmailing the gates family
have both denied these allegations even
if someone was trying to extort matt
gates
and or his family the mere fact of the
extortion
wouldn't change any of the criminal
guilt associated with those alleged acts
so we'll see what happens with the
extortion now if there's one lesson we
can take away from any of that it's that
if you are potentially
a criminal defendant you probably
shouldn't put inculpatory evidence in
your venmo history but if you are going
to pay for illicit activity over venmo
then you'll need a good cell phone
provider and the best
is ting mobile i personally switched to
t-mobile why well because of this yes
that is a real cell phone bill that i
got with my previous provider and it's
why i personally switched to ting mobile
and ting mobile has three brand new
plans to make sure that that never
happens to you
you can get talk and text for only 10 a
month data plans starting at 25
a month and unlimited for 45 dollars a
month switching plans is actually really
easy because you can keep your same
phone number and use pretty much any
phone that you want
and the service is great too because
ting partners with several massive
networks
probably the very same one that you're
using right now but
you get a huge discount now actually i
can't tell you which ones because i
always respect contracts but let's just
say that my service
hasn't changed at all now i've been on
the phone with my previous providers for
hours over the
simplest things or trying to deal with
huge bills
but they always put me on hold but with
ting you can call them up and
immediately talk to a real human being
or you can talk to them on chat
discord you name it they are available
and it's incredibly easy to transfer
your service just by simply ordering a
sim card
popping it in and setting it up no phone
calls required at all it's like magic
and if you're around wi-fi all the time
and you don't need an unlimited plan
like you're working from home then you
have the flexibility to save hundreds of
dollars a year
because ting still gives you the option
to just pay for what you use with their
flex plan
it's a smarter cheaper version of the
same plan that they've always had
and now they just give you the
possibility of unlimited versions as
well
so if you want unlimited you can go
absolutely crazy so if you'd like to try
out my mobile provider ting mobile just
go to legaleagle.ting.com
legal eagles will get a special 25
credit that could cover
two months of service or you can just
click on the link in the description and
give it a try plus
clicking on that link in the description
really helps out this channel
so do you agree with my analysis leave
your objections in the comments and
please
do not put evidence of illegal activity
in your venmo history but
do check out this playlist with all my
other real law reviews where i tackle
the legal issues of the day
so click on this playlist or i'll see
you in court